First, let's build up
the conceptual mechanics
for these new types
of random algorithms
which accept some input
n, and if n is prime,
our algorithm will output
prime with 100% certainty,
and it will never
label it as composite.
However, if n is
composite, then there
will be some tiny
chance of error,
e, that it will label it
prime, otherwise there is a 1
minus this tiny
error probability
that it will correctly
identify it as composite.
So we'll start simple.
Out of some universe of
integers up to some limit,
we grab a number and
call this integer n.
And we input n into our machine.
And previously in our
trial division methods,
we basically iterated
through all values
from 1 to the square
root of n, and tested
if that number divides in.
And ideally, we only wanted
to check primes to save time.
And if yes, a divides
n, then we know
that n is a composite
number, because we
found a composite witness.
If not, then we are not sure.
So we go back and we increment
a, and we test again.
And once we exhausted
all possible tests,
we could then say yes, n is
prime if we found no divisors.
But now let's be lazy.
What if we just pick
a few random integers
and do a few
divisibility tests, which
you can think of as
random questions.
Since we know that some
number n, if it's composite,
it must have some
divisors scattered around.
And at minimum, it
has a single divisor.
And some composite numbers
have many divisors.
So anyway, we picked a
random integer a between 1
and the square root
of n, and that's it.
Then we just checked
if a divides n.
And as before, if a
divides n, then we
know for sure that
n is composite.
We found a witness.
If not, then we haven't
learned too much,
except that it could be prime.
So to be safe, we could
generate a few more random
a's, and keep testing.
And perhaps after 100 or 1,000
iterations, we could stop
and say it's probably
prime with some certainty.
Say, for example, 99.9%.
And this is similar
to the example
game on conditional probability.
In the simplest
version, we were trying
to guess if a coin was fair,
or if it was a two headed coin.
In this case, tails is
like finding a divisor.
It's a witness of a fair coin.
Heads is the case where
we might want the person
to flip again and iterate.
In this case, after around five
heads, we are more than 90%
sure, so we could
stop and say, oh, we
think the coin is two headed.
So here's a program I've set
up which compares our old trial
division methods with this
new random division test.
And I'm specifically using the
current trial division speed
leader, which is
a program by Dino,
and I posted the link in
the header of the program.
So to begin, notice the
variable number of trials.
This is the number
of random guesses.
So we'll start at something
small, such as three.
And notice even with small
input, if the input is prime,
the random division algorithm
will always output prime.
But when the input
is composite, we
see the random division can
make mistakes and identify it
incorrectly as prime.
However, we can fix
this by increasing
the number of trials, and then
the probability of an error
goes down.
And we see now that the
outputs more or less match.
And as I test larger
input, the error
grows again, so I
need to increase
the number of random
tests accordingly.
And when I do, the
outputs match very nicely.
They seem identical.
But with huge input
size, I need thousands
of random tests for
this to be accurate.
So we haven't actually improved
the number of steps needed.
Our trial division method
still seems better.
This is because the error
rate of the division test
is so high, but we are close.
We have the right idea.
So we need to use another test.
We need an equation, which
is fast to calculate,
that can be used to prove
whether a number is composite.
And it must accept not only
the input integer n, but also
a random integer a
and do a random test
in the same sort of way.